hi there hopefully this is going let me
see yeah i can't really see too well
because the sun's in my face
[Music]
today i want to talk about
learning languages in the moment
and this is something that applies to so
many things that we do in life
very often we're looking forward to
what's going to happen tomorrow or we
have goals of what we want to achieve
but sometimes we just have to focus on
what we're enjoying right now
by the way if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe you can click on the
little bell in order to get a
notification
and if you want to learn languages the
way i do please join us at lincoln
now
i was thinking of this as i was driving
up to whistler western bc which is where
i am right now
and it's about an hour and 15 minutes
from my home it's a spectacular place
mountains uh i'll kind of swing this
around maybe you can see the mountains
up there i don't know
uh we're staying at this unit here for
two nights my wife and i just to get a
little break from being hunkered down
because of covet
so and the drive up here is just
spectacular you drive along a fjord howe
sound then you drive inland and you've
got mountains surrounding you
and i might intersperse this video with
some pictures if we take some more
pictures we're going to play a bit of
golf here it's very warm it's i think
it's like 27 28 degrees it's supposed to
go up to 32 we're going to pemberton
which is another 45 minutes down the
road play a golf course called big sky
i'm driving up here
with my wife and we're listening to a
podcast about the byzantine empire
so i'm enjoying the drive
i'm enjoying listening to the byzantine
empire at the podcast
and why am i listening to a podcast
about the byzantine empire because i've
been learning
arabic and persian and turkish
so i'm kind of exploring that part of
the world
and so i've read books now on the
persian history of persia or of iran on
history of
arabic countries
prior to islam post-islam colonial
period and lo and behold i read a book
on the byzantine empire which is
something we learned so little about so
all of these things that spring from my
learning of the language
are things that i enjoy and while i'm
doing them reading in english i'm
enjoying that but when i'm in with the
language if i'm doing our mini stories
in arabic and i'm
kind of rediscovering things that i
learned and forgot in the sort of mini
stories the simple vocabulary the basic
structures
or i get this you know giddy feeling
that i actually understand
the say al jazeera podcast when they
talk about uh
you know the united arab emirates deal
with israel mutual recognition what that
means tensions in the middle east and
i'm hearing it from
someone from the area in arabic although
until i actually start reading it and
saving words looking them up i don't
necessarily understand that much but i
understand quite a bit of it so i enjoy
that
i'm not thinking about the day when i'll
be fluent in arabic and i know i will
get there but i'm actually enjoying the
time that i spend with the language now
and i think this applies to everything
we do we can turn around and i can look
at the trees or even at my home i can
look at the the texture of my pine
flooring or a carpet that we bought in
beijing
50 years ago or in hong kong i don't
remember
and in fact i tweeted about that so i
think it's important always to
focus on what you're doing in the moment
and it's really important in language
learning because
we have to believe that what we are
doing is important and enjoyable you
want to enjoy what you're doing so if
you're learning a language and you're
saying this is boring but i'm hoping
that someday it'll be worth it for me
to me that is not as powerful as as i'm
enjoying what i'm doing now this is what
i want to be doing there's all kinds of
other things i can do but i'll do those
later
right now i'm enjoying being in my
language
and and of course what's so wonderful in
today's world i thought about this again
as i was preparing my trip up here with
my wife and of course i just finished
this book on the byzantine empire
discussing byzantine's strategy and how
they managed to play
different you know step people and other
enemies against each other so that they
survived for a thousand years after all
the byzantine empire survived
up until 1453
so then i said well
i wonder if there's a podcast on this so
i go to a
app called pocket cast or something like
that
and lo and behold there are podcasts on
everything and there are if i if i for
example take the word arabia for arabic
and i put that in the search i find all
kinds of arabic podcasts persian podcast
french podcast spanish podcast
all of these things are available to us
i haven't yet done any research to find
which of these have transcripts because
i require transcripts certainly in
arabic and persian to unders understand
what's being said but i know there's
this tremendous quantity of material out
there and i can actually listen to
a podcast in arabic even without having
the transcripts and and it's new and
it's interesting and i pick up certain
things and even that is enjoyable so i
just want to emphasize this idea that
you know obviously to be successful in
language learning you have to believe in
what you're doing you have to believe
that you can succeed
so
the belief that you will succeed in
becoming fluent is kind of projecting
into the future but at the same time you
have to find ways to enjoy what you're
doing now because if you enjoy what
you're doing it's going to come into
your brain you're going to stay with it
you're going to put in the time you're
going to stay positive so that you will
eventually
achieve your goal if you can
you know enjoy what you're doing in the
moment so that's what i wanted to say
about learning in the moment
bye for now
[Music]
you